30S THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATE ACTIONS WILL NOW
COME TO ORDER. SO, GOOD MORNING,
EVERYONE. TODAY WE'RE HOLDING
OUR HEARING HERE IN ROOM 2200 OF
THE Þ STREET BUILDING. WE ARE
ALSO LIVE STREAMING THE HEARING
TODAY. SO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC,
MEMBERS AND THEIR STAFF HAVE AN
OPTION TO BE HERE IN PERSON OR
TO FOLLOW ALONG FROM A DISTANCE.
AS A REMINDER TO EVERYONE OUT
THERE, TODAY'S HEARING CONSISTS
ONLY OF ITEMS THAT ARE ON THE
SUSPENSE FILE. ALL OF THESE
MEASURES HAVE ALREADY HAD A
HEARING IN THIS COMMITTEE, WITH
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. AS NOTED IN THE DAILY
FILE, THE SUSPENSE FILE HEARING
IS A VOTE ONLY HEARING WITH NO
TESTIMONY. Kò I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK MY FELLOW MEMBERS, THEIR
STAFFS, AND ESPECIALLY THE STAFF
ON THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FOR ALL OF THEIR ASSISTANCE AND
HARD WORK ON THESE IMPORTANT
MEASURES. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK OUR VICE CHAIR, SENATOR
JONES, AND HIS FISCAL
CONSULTANTS, FOR BEING GOOD
PARTNERS IN THIS PROCESS. ICE.
BEFORE WE COMMENCE, I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A FEW BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENTS
ABOUT HOW WE WILL PROCEED SO
THAT THE PUBLIC, MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAFF CAN FOLLOW
ALONG. WE WILL BE MOVING QUICKLY
THROUGH THE AGENDA
ALPHABETICALLY, IN AUTHOR ORDER.
PLEASE PAY CLOSE ATTENTION, AS
WE WILL ONLY BE ADDRESSING
MEASURES THAT WILL BE UP FOR A
VOTE THIS MORNING. IF YOU DON'T
HEAR ME, TAKE UP A PARTICULAR
MEASURE. THAT BILL IS HELD UNDER
SUBMISSION. AS WE GO THROUGH THE
AGENDA, I WILL ANNOUNCE THE
AUTHOR OF THE MEASURE NUMBER AND
PROVIDE A BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF
ANY AMENDMENTS TO THE MEASURE
BEFORE WE TAKE THE VOTE. BEFORE
WE FORMALLY BEGIN THE HEARING, I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
MAKE A FEW BRIEF COMMENTS. THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS WILL BE
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
AND BUDGET PROCESS. REYES AS WE
WORK TO MAKE HARD DECISIONS TO
ADVANCE OUR STATE'S PRIORITIES,
TO SUPPORT WORKING FAMILIES
WHILE LIVING WITHIN OUR MEANS.
FINDING BALANCE WILL BE CRITICAL
TO ENSURING THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO MAKE OUR GOVERNMENT WORK
EFFICIENTLY AND PRUDENTLY FOR
ALL WORKING FAMILIES. I
APPRECIATE THE I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUES TO
BE PRUDENT AND REASONABLE IN
THEIR FISCAL ANALYSIS OF EACH
BILL, AND MANY OF THEM WORKED
REALLY HARD TO TRY TO REDUCE THE
COSTS AND TO STILL ALL, YOU
KNOW, WORK ON BILLS THAT THAT
THEY WERE PASSIONATE ABOUT.
FOLLOWING THE HEARING, WE WILL
BE POSTING THE HEARING RESULTS
AND THE ACTIONS TAKEN ON EACH
MEASURE ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AT W-W-W DOT SAPR DOT
SENATE DOT CA.GOV. IN ADDITION,
FOR ANY BILLS THAT ARE BEING
AMENDED TODAY, WE WILL BE
HOSTING AN ADDENDUM ANALYSIS
WHICH I KNOW YOU'VE ALL BEEN
WAITING FOR, WHICH INCLUDES A
SUMMARY OF THE AMENDMENTS AND
THE REVISED FISCAL IMPACTS OF
THE AMENDED BILL. THESE SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE ONLINE WITHIN AN
HOUR OF THE HEARING'S
CONCLUSION. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN BY ESTABLISHING A QUORUM.
SO MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CABALLERO. HERE.
CABALLERO. HERE. JONES. I'M
HERE. JONES. HERE. ASHBY. HERE.
ASHBY. HERE. BECKER HERE.
BECKER. HERE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. HERE. CIERTO CIERTO.
HERE. WAHAB. WAHAB. HERE WE ARE
ALL HERE, WHICH IS GREAT. OKAY,
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR
FIRST ITEM ON THE AGENDA. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH SENATOR
ALLEN AND WE'LL START WITH SB
1143 EPR HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS
WASTE. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED TO EXEMPT CERTAIN PET
PET MEDICATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE AYE. JONES
NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO
CIERTO. NO. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 5
TO 2. THAT BILL IS OUT. SB 1231
BY SENATOR ALLEN. PRODUCT
PACKAGING EPR AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ADVERTISING. MOTION IS DUE PASS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO
AYE. CAPITO. AYE. JONES. JONES.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO. CIERTO.
AYE WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 7070. THAT
BILL IS OUT. SB 1234, COASTAL
RESOURCES. LOCAL LAND USE PLANS.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS LET ME JUST
READ THAT. WE WILL. WE ARE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
MOVING ON TO SB 1297. CITY OF
MALIBU. SPEED SAFETY SYSTEM.
PILOT PROGRAM. MOTION IS Dð
PASS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
JONES. NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY.
ASHBY AYE. BECKER I. BECKER.
AYE. BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE.
CIERTO. CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE THE. THE ROLL CALL IS
6 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT SB
1332. THE CONSERVATION
STEWARDSHIP STEWARDSHIP FUND.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS WE WERE
GOING WE ARE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1339
SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY RESIDENCES.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
PER AUTHOR, TO REVISE
CERTIFICATION FEE AMOUNTS AND TO
DELETE THE REQUIRED REPORT.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. 1341 PUPIL
INSTRUCTION IN MEDIA ARTS.
AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB TO DO PASS
MOTION. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1406 RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES
FOR THE ELDERLY. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. SB 1450 BY SENATOR ALLEN.
ELECTIONS TASK FORCE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
JONES ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
BECKER BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO CIERTO.
AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 6 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT. 6 TO 0. SB
1461. STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
LOCAL EMERGENCY. DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE DEFINITION
. THE WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. NEXT AUTHOR IS
SENATOR ALVARADO. GIL WILL START
WITH SB 945 WILDFIRE SMOKE AND
HEALTH OUTCOMES. MOTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED PER AUTHOR TO
REMOVE THE ARB THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1088 OS WATER SYSTEM
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS. THE
MOTION IS Dð. PASS WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT VOTE IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1197 READ REGIONAL CENTER
IN-HOME RESPITE CARE. MOTION IS
Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT VOTE IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AND SB
1261 STATE DESIGNATED FARES.
ALLOCATION OF REVENUES. THE
MOTION IS Dð. PASS AS AMENDED,
TO REDUCE THE TRANSFER OF 3%
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231, AND
THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AND SB
1396. CAL WORKS HOME VISITING
PROGRAM. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SEE WHO SAYS
THAT? WE DON'T ALL GET ALONG, SO
THEN WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE ON
TO SENATOR ARCHULETA. WE WILL
START WITH SB 1081, SELECTIVE
SERVICE REGISTRATION, DRIVER'S
LICENSE APPLICATIONS. THE MOTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED PER AUTHOR
TO EXEMPT AB 60 LICENSE HOLDERS.
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION AND MAKE
CONTINGENT UPON FEDERAL FUNDING.
THIS, WE WILL DO A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THIS. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. NO JONES.
NO. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
CIERTO. CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB. NO
WAHAB. NO. 42. GOING TO
RECONSIDER. THAT BILL IS OUT. 4
TO 2. MOVING ON TO SB 1262
SUPERVISED RELEASE. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO NARROW
THE SCOPE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1315 SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY
ANNUAL REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS, AND
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO SB
1330, URBAN RETAIL WATER
SUPPLIER WATER USE, THE MOTION
IS Dð PASS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. CAPITAL I, CAPITAL I JONES
JONES I ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER I
BECKER I BRADFORD BRADFORD I
CIERTO CIERTO I WAHAB. NO SORRY
WAHAB NO SIX ZERO 6 TO 0 THAT
BILL SHE SAID NO OH 6 TO 1 6 TO
1 I'M SORRY. 6 TO 1. THAT'S
RIGHT. THANK YOU. THAT BILL IS
OUT. MOVING ON TO SB 1465
SUBSTANDARD BUILDINGS CODE
ENFORCEMENT, THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. NOW I'D LIKE TO
MOVE ON TO SENATOR ASHBY, THE
FIRST BILL IS SB 989 DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. JONES AYE.
JONES. AYE. ASHBY AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE. SATO
SATO. NO. WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB NOT
VOTING. OH, I'M SO SORRY. OKAY.
RIGHT, I MISS MISHEARD MY
APOLOGIES. WE GOT YOU. SO 6 TO
0, THAT, THAT IS THE VOTE IS 6
TO 0. THE BILL IS OUT. SB 1000
CONNECTED DEVICES. THE MOTION IS
Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE
CLARIFYING AND TECHNICAL CHANGES
. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. AND THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0, SB 1180 HEALTH
COVERAGE. EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO MAKE THE MEDI-CAL
BENEFIT SUBJECT TO FEDERAL
FUNDING AND APPROPRIATION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO
AYE. CABALLERO AYE AYE. JONES.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD BRADFORD.
AYE. SATO WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB. AYE
5 TO 0. 5 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT
. SB 1477. SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY
CHARTER SCHOOLS. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED PER AUTHOR,
TO REMOVE ADMINISTRATIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1498 CANNABIS
ADVERTISING. AND CIVIL ACTION.
THE MOTION IS Dð. PASS WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1502. ZALEHA
XYLAZINE. OKAY, WELL. IT'S JUST
KIND OF CAUGHT MY ATTENTION.
XYLAZINE. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED TO ADD A COAUTHOR,
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1452
ARCHITECTS BOARD AND LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTS TECHNICAL COMMITTEE
MOTION IS A DUE PASS, AND WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. THE TAKE A TAKE A MOMENT
BACK UP IN THE LINE. OKAY I
THINK YOU NEED TO EXPLAIN HOW
YOU DIVIDED THE BILLS. OH, YEAH.
SORRY. THE, THE COMMITTEE BILLS
ARE KIND OF OUT OF ORDER JUST
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT WE
SEPARATED THEM OUT. ON SPORTS.
SPORTS. JUST TAKE A REAL QUICK
BREAK HERE.
OKAY. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH THE,
THE BOARD, BILLS. AND THE NEXT
ONE IS SB 1453. AND THIS IS THE
DENTAL BOARD. THE ACTION IS Dð.
PASS THIS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE OUT THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. THE NEXT IS SB 1454,
WHICH IS THE BUREAU OF SECURITY
AND INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS, AND WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO SB 1455,
WHICH IS THE CONTRACTOR STATE
LICENSE BOARD. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR,
TO REQUIRE THE CSLB TO CREATE A
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE
EXEMPTION PROCESS FOR LICENSEES.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AND FINALLY, SB
1456, WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ATHLETIC COMMISSION.
MOTION IS DUE PASS, AND WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FOR SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO, SENATOR,
FOR, PRO TEM EMERITUS ATKINS SB
1213 BREAST AND CERVICAL CANCER
PROGRAM. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FOR SB 1231. THAT BILL
IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. THEN WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE, SENATOR BECKER
NØ. WE'LL START WE'LL START WITH
THAT WAS PRETTY DEFINITIVE.
WE'LL START WITH SB 942 CALIF AI
TRANSPARENCY ACT. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS IS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
K¾T REGISTRY, THIS IS A ROLL
CALL VOTE. CABALLERO AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE JONES. ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. CIERTO WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE FIVE ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT.
5 TO 0. SB 1060. PROPERTY
INSURANCE UNDERWRITING RISK
MODELS. THE MOTION IS Dð PASSES
AMENDED TO MAKE PERMISSIVE,
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH THE REPUBLICANS,
VOTING NO. SB 1120 HEALTH CARE,
HEALTH COVERAGE UTILIZATION
REVIEW. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SUBSTITUTE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1133 BEALL Dð PASSES AMENDED PER
AUTHOR TO REQUIRE TO REQUIRE
BAIL REVIEW HEARINGS TO OCCUR AT
REGULARLY SCHEDULED COURT DATES,
AND AMEND TO NARROW THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH THE
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 1161
JUVENILES MOTION IS DUE. PASS
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1254 FRESH
CAL FRESH INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS. THE MOTION IS DO
PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO DELETE THE COMBINED
APPLICATION AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. AMEND TO DELETE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR COUNTY WORKERS
TO ENTER PRISONS IN JAIL. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1288, THE SCHOOL I
WORKING GROUP THE MOTION. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF MEETINGS AND ALLOW
TELECONFERENCING WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231, THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1374 NET ENERGY METERING. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CABALLERO AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. JONES. JONES NØ.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER.
BECKER AYE. BRADFORD. CIERTO.
CIERTO NO. WAHAB A WAHAB. AYE
4242. THAT BILL IS OUT NOW.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
SENATOR BLAKE SPARE STARTING
WITH SB 1002. FIREARMS
PROHIBITED PERSONS. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS IN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
7 TO 0 VOTE. SB 1019 FIREARMS
DESTRUCTION. THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE, THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1045
COMPOSTING FACILITIES. ZONING.
AIR AND WATER PERMITS. MOTION IS
Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1053 REUSABLE
GROCERY BAGS. MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
CHANGE THE PAPER BAG STANDARD AT
250% RECYCLED CONTENT. BLESS
YOU. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. SB 1066 EPR MARINE FLARES. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1077 LCP AMENDMENTS ON ADUS
DO. THE MOTION IS DUE, PASSED
AND WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL ON
THIS. CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. JONES A JONES AYE. ASHBY.
AYE ASHBY AYE. BECKER A BECKER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CIERTO. CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB.
NO WAHAB. NO. 6 TO 1. THAT BILL
IS OUT. 6 TO 1 SB 1092. COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMITS APPEALS. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO ADJUST THE
DUE DATE AND CONTENTS OF THE
REPORT, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON
THE UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1098, THE LUZON RAIL CORRIDOR
CORRIDOR. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
REQUIRE CALSTAR TO LEAD THE
WORKING GROUP AND THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY AND CONSOLIDATE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON. WE'RE
GETTING, WE'RE RIPPING THROUGH
THE NOW. I CAN'T EVEN THINK
ANYMORE. NO I WAS GOING TO SAY
THE ALPHABET, BUT WE'RE STILL ON
B, SENATOR BRADFORD, WE'LL START
WITH SB 1050, THE CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN FREEDMEN AFFAIRS
AGENCY, THE ACTION IS DUE PASS,
AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM, SB 1143. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB
1059 CANNABIS. LOCAL TAXATION ON
GROSS RECEIPTS. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. JONES. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. SATO
SATO. AYE. WAHAB. NO. WAHAB. NO
6 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT. 6 TO
1. MOVING ON TO SB 1109.
CANNABIS LICENSE APPLICANTS.
DEMOGRAPHIC. DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR,
TO INSTEAD APPLY REQUIREMENTS TO
LICENSE APPLICANTS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR SB
1143, THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1130 FARAH
ELIGIBILITY MOTION IS DUE PASS.
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1143. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB
1292 ELECTRICITY FIXED CHARGES.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1328 ELECTIONS. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1331 REPARATIONS AND
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FUND MOTION
IS DUE PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
REMOVE PROVISIONS REQUIRING
TRANSFERS FROM THE SPECIAL FUND
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. SB 1383, THE CÁC BROAD PUBLIC
BROADBAND PUBLIC HOUSING ACCOUNT
MOTION IS DUE PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1403 CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
FREEDMEN AFFAIRS AGENCY MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REQUIRE SENATE
CONFIRMATION OF THE SECRETARY
AND MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES WHEN
A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. MOVING ON
TO ZERO. STARTING WITH SB 1123.
PLANNING AND ZONING. SUB
SUBDIVISIONS. MINISTERIAL
REVIEW. THE MOTION IS DO PASS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I CAVERO I
JONES. NO. JONES. NO ASHBY I
ASHBY I BECKER I BECKER I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I SATO. WAHAB
I WAHAB I 5 TO 1, 5 TO 1. THAT
BILL IS OUT SB 1303 PUBLIC
WORKS. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1143. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
SB 1390 GROUNDWATER RECHARGE,
FLOOD FLOW DIVERSIONS DO PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1420
HYDROGEN. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
REVISE SPECIFIC STANDARDS FOR
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN AND APPLY
THEM ONLY FOR IN-STATE
INCENTIVES AND TO PROHIBIT
BIOMASS COMBUSTION FACILITIES
FROM USING EXPEDITED JUDICIAL
REVIEW. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
JONES. NON-VOTING. ASHBY A ASHBY
. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE. SATO.
WAHAB THAT BILL IS OUT 44 TO 0.
SB 1432. HOSPITAL SEISMIC
STANDARDS. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR. TO
FURTHER SPECIFY N N. TO FURTHER
SPECIFY HOSPITAL AND DEPARTMENT
REQUIREMENTS, AND DELETE
PROVISIONS RELATED TO RURAL
HOSPITALS, WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO SENATOR
CORTESE. SB 9908 FENTANYL CHILD
DEATHS. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED TO ADD A COAUTHOR,
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231 THAT THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 915 LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
LIMIT LOCAL REGULATORY AUTHORITY
TO 15 LARGEST CITIES. CITIES
ALLOW NEIGHBORING JURISDICTIONS
TO ADOPT A SUSTAINED A
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR ORDINANCE,
PROHIBIT AV BANS, AND MAKE A
CLARIFYING CHANGE, WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A 5 TO 2 VOTE, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 999
HEALTH COVERAGE, MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
MOTION IS Dð PASS, WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 11, SB
1015 NURSING SCHOOLS AND
PROGRAMS. CLINICAL PLACEMENTS.
MOTION IS DUE PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1162 PUBLIC CONTRACTS.
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENTS. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1298
CERTIFICATION OF THERMAL POWER
PLANTS DATA CENTERS. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS IS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE THE CEC TO DETERMINE A
FACILITY WILL RESULT IN THE
LOWEST TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE
EMISSION OF CRITERIA. AIR
POLLUTANTS, TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS, AND GHGS. BEFORE
ISSUING AN EXEMPTION AS
SPECIFIED THAT, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MADAM
CHAIR, YES, I HAVE A VOTE ON
THAT ONE, I APOLOGIZE. OKAY, NO
PROBLEM. WE'LL WE'LL. THAT WAS
1298. YOU JUST CALLED, RIGHT?
1298. YES. SO CAN YOU, DO A
REQUEST FOR A, MAKE A MOTION
FOR. HOLD ON ONE MOMENT. OKAY.
CAN WE PAUSE? YEAH.
SO, SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE ASKING
FOR RECONSIDERATION. YEAH MADAM
CHAIR, I'D LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION
FOR RECONSIDERATION ON SB 1298.
COURTESY, PLEASE. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO THAT, THERE IS NO
OBJECTION. SO, THE MOTION PASSES
AND, LET'S CALL THE ROLL ON SB
1298. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO A CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. ASHBY AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO. CIERTO
AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE THAT BILL
IS OUT 6 TO 0. MOVING ON TO SB
1298. FARM WORKER BENEFITS THE
MOTION Ó 99. DID I SAY OKAY
1299 FARM WORKER BENEFITS. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH THREE
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. ALL
RIGHTY. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
SENATOR DOLLY. WE'LL START WITH
SB 1062 CONVERSION OF BIOMASS
ENERGY GENERATION FACILITIES.
THAT MOTION IS DUE PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1163 WILDFIRE
WILDLIFE VEHICLE COLLISIONS. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASSES AMENDED TO
MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231, THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1207 BY CLEAN CALIFORNIA ACT
ELIGIBLE MATERIALS. MOTION IS Dð
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1258 MEDI-CAL
PROVIDER OVERPAYMENTS MOTION IS
DUE PASS. AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AND
FINALLY, SB 1423 CRITICAL ACCESS
HOSPITALS MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
AN APPROPRIATION. AND WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231 SO THAT THE
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SENATOR DODD
WILL START WITH SB 896, THE AI
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED PER AUTHOR,
TO REMOVE ADDS PROVISIONS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231 AND THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 958 SURPLUS STATE
PROPERTY COUNTY OF NAPA MOTION
IS DUE PASS WHEN SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1003 WILD
FIRE MITIGATION PLANS. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1014 CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE
MITIGATION STRATEGIC PLANNING
ACT. THE MOTION IS Dð. PASS AS
AMENDED. TO NARROW THE SCOPE.
I'M GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. SB 1159 SEQUA ROADSIDE
ROADSIDE WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION
PROJECTS. MOTION IS TO PASS
AGAIN. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1166 PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION THÀNH
TITLE NINE REPORTING MOTION IS
Dð. PASS AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1380 CHARTER SCHOOL PETITIONS.
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
NARROW THE ABILITY FOR DISTRICTS
IN FINANCIAL DISTRESS TO
CONSIDER THE FISCAL IMPACT OF A
NEW CHARTER PETITION AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES AND AMEND TO
REMOVE THE COUNTYWIDE PROVISIONS
, WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. AND SB 1384 POWERED WHEELCHAIR
RIGHT TO REPAIR. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. OKAY.
MOVING ON TO SENATOR DURAZO.
WE'LL START WITH SB 1090
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE,
DISABILITY AND PAID FAMILY
LEAVE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1201 BENEFICIAL
OWNERS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION, REMOVE THE
RIGHTS ORTEZ RIGHTS, AND
AUTHORIZE FEE INCREASE THROUGH
REGULATION. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143 AND
THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A 5 TO
2 VOTE WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. SB 1255 PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS
NEEDS ANALYSIS. MOTION IS DUE
PASS. AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. AND THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 1325
BY SENATOR DURAZZO. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. SB 1375 WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT,
POVERTY REDUCING STANDARDS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM 1143. THAT BILL
IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB
1447 CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL LÀ
SEISMIC COMPLIANCE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1460
BROADBAND LABOR STANDARDS ACT
MOTION IS DUE PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. FINALLY,
SB 1500 FEDERAL HOUSING WAIVER.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. AND
AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. MOVING ON TO SENATOR EGGMAN.
WE START WITH SB 1025 PRETRIAL
DIVERSION FOR VETERANS. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON
A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 1118
SOMA PROGRAM. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE,
VOTE. CABALLERO A CABALLERO AYE.
JONES NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE BECKER I. BECKER I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE. SATO
IHAB. WAHAB. AYE 5 TO 1. THAT
BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 1 SB 1237. THE
LADDERMAN PET PETE SB 1238. THE
LAND THURMOND PETRIS SHORT ACT.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1333 HIV REPORTING.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231 THAT THAT BILL
IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. SB 1397 HEALTH PLANS,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231, THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1491 EQUITY IN HIGHER EDUCATION
ACT. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
REMOVE THE LÀ Ó ASSESSMENT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. NOW WE'RE ON TO SENATOR
GLAZER. WE'LL START WITH SB
1200. CSU CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM MOTION IS TO PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
MOVING ON TO SB 1217 PET
INSURANCE, THE MOTION IS TO PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1256 DNA COLLECTION.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO NARROW THE SCOPE
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1287. POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION HARASSMENT,
INTIMIDATION, AND DISCRIMINATION
DO PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REVISE COAUTHORS,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. JONES.
JONES. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
CIERTO. CIERTO AYE. WAHAB 5 TO
0. 5 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. SB
1327 INCOME TAX CREDITS. LOCAL
NEWS MEDIA, DATA EXTRACTION
TRANSACTIONS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR,
TO DEFINE TERMS, MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES, MODIFYING MODIFY
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS AND ADD
COAUTHOR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
JONES 1327. NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER BRADFORD.
CIERTO. NO. CIERTO. NO. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE MORE TIME. BECKER. I'M
VOTING. BRADFORD SORRY. BRADFORD
WE'LL PUT THIS ON. ON CALL.
MOVING ON TO SB 1382. HEALTH
CLINICS BUILDING STANDARDS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1404 POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
1974 AUDITS MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. JONES. JONES
NÓ. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 1. THAT
BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 1. SB 1415.
CALWORKS. HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
DELETE EDUCATIONAL PAYMENTS AND
DELETE REPORTS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1482 COMMERCIAL FINANCING.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED
PER AUTHOR, TO REVISE REGULATORY
STRUCTURE, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
JONES. NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
CIERTO AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 6
TO 1. 6 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT.
SB 1487. VEHICLES. PARKING
VIOLATIONS. THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1499 PERSONAL INCOME TAX
RETIREMENT ACCOUNT CATCH UP
LIMITS. MOTION IS Dð. PASS
NGUYEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0, MOVING ON TO SENATOR
GONZALEZ STARTING WITH SB 930
FOR ZERO EMISSION FREIGHT
CENTRAL DELIVERY TEAM. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MODIFY
REPORTING WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143, THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. SB 991 LAUSD OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS. SORRY, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1016 LATINO AND
INDIGENOUS DISPARITIES REDUCTION
ACT. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR. TO
REMOVE CALFRESH PROVISIONS,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. BECKER. BECKER.
AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE.
CIERTO. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 5 TO
0. 5 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. SB
1131 MEDI-CAL PROVIDERS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO DELETE
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANCE PROVISIONS
AND MAKE THE FAMILY PACT
REVISIONS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1182, THE MASTER
PLAN FOR HEALTHY, SUSTAINABLE
AND CLIMATE RESILIENT SCHOOLS.
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
REMOVE REQUIRING THE STEER, THE
STEERING TEAM, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE CABALLERO.
AYE. JONES. AYE. JONES. AYE
ASHBY A ASHBY. AYE. BECKER
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. SATO WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE THAT
BILL IS OUT 6 TO 0. SB 1253.
FIREARM SAFETY CERTIFICATES. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO LIMIT THE SCOPE TO THE
REQUIREMENT THAT A PERSON OBTAIN
A FIREARM SAFETY CERTIFICATE
WHEN MOVING INTO THE STATE WITH
A GUN. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THE
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. SB 1425 OIL TRUST FUND. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO CHANGE THE AMOUNT TRANSFERRED
, THAT WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO
SENATOR GROVE, SB 974 LITHIUM
EXTRACTION TAX DISTRIBUTION
FUND. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1043 SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS MOTION IS DUE PASS,
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1264 BY
SENATOR GROVE. EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION. CANNABIS USE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. AGAIN,
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AND SB 1414 VÌ,
SOLICITATION. SOLICITATION OF A
MINOR. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS,
AS AMENDED PER AUTHOR, TO ADD
COAUTHORS AND AMEND TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO SENATOR
HURTADO. SB 1151 POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF 1974. FOREIGN
AGENTS. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1243. EXTREME WEATHER
CONDITIONS. PHYSICAL ACTIVITY
FOR STUDENTS 1248 I'M SORRY, SB
1248 EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS.
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY FOR STUDENTS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AGAIN.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO
SENATOR JONES, WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH SB 1074. THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED
, TO MAKE CLARIFYING AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES. AGAIN, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. AND SB 1443. THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL IS
DO PASS, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE CALL FROM SB 1231.
THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO SENATOR LEONARD, SB 931,
THE MEMORIAL HIGHWAY SIGNAGE
FUND. THE MOTION IS, 930. I'M
SORRY. I'M. SOMETHING'S
HAPPENING WITH MY EYEBALLS,
ACTUALLY, I'M JUST CHECKING TO
SEE IF ANYBODY'S PAYING
ATTENTION, SNEAK SOME MORE OF MY
BILLS IN HERE. SB 930, MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY SIGNAGE FUND. THE MOTION
IS Dð PASS NGUYEN A SUBSTITUTE.
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. SB 977, COUNTY OF SAN LUIS
OBISPO REDISTRICT. REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND AGAIN,
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. SB 1064 CANNABIS LICENSES DO
PASS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION AND MAKE
CONFORMING CHANGES, AS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1188 DRINKING WATER TÊ EMF
STANDARDS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
ALIGN WITH THE US EPA. AGAIN,
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE. BLESS
YOU. WE'RE IN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. AND THEN SB 1205 WORKER'S
COMPENSATION MEDICAL BENEFITS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED PER AUTHOR, TO SPECIFY
THAT AN EMPLOYER MAY REQUIRE AN
EMPLOYEE TO FIRST EXHAUST LEAVE
CREDITS. BUT AGAIN, WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. MOVING ON
TO SENATOR LIMON, WE'LL START
WITH SB 1036 VOLUNTARY CARBON
OFFSETS REGULATION IN THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REFINE TERMS. EXEMPT
VOCS USED IN CALIFORNIA'S
COMPLIANCE MARKET AND ALLOW
GREATER FLEXIBILITY FOR REQUIRED
DISCLOSURES AS SPECIFIED WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 1061
MEDICAL DEBT. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. AND AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AND SB 1094 PUPIL
INSTRUCTIONS. SOCIAL SCIENCES
AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. THE MOTION
IS DO PASS. AND AGAIN WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 1101
PRESCRIBED FIRE MAPPING MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO ALIGN
MAPPING REQUIREMENTS WITH
EXISTING CAL FIRE EFFORTS. THE
SUBSTITUTE ROLL CALL FROM 1231
WILL BE USED, AND THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1152 FIRE SAFETY
REGULATIONS. LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES. MOTION IS Dð. PASS
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1220 PUBLIC
BENEFITS CONTRACTS, PHONE
OPERATOR JOBS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO EXEMPT 988 AND 211
FROM OUT OF STATE CONTRACT
PROHIBITIONS AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. AGAIN. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICAN
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 1246
CALIFORNIA PROMPT PAYMENT ACT
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS MOTION
IS DUE PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE.
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1304
UNDERGROUND INJECTION CONTROL
AQUIFER EXEMPTION. MOTION IS DUE
PASS. I'M GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FOR SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. SB 1433 GRAVITY BASED ENERGY
STORAGE WELL, PILOT PROGRAM
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO AUTHORIZE A
PROGRAM FEE, ADD A NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT, AND CAP THE NUMBER
OF WELLS. ROLL CALL, PLEASE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
JONES. ASHBY. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD A
BRADFORD. AYE. SATO. NO. SATO.
NO. WAHAB AYE. WAHAB. AYE 5 TO
1. THAT BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 1. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO SENATE, THE,
PRO TEM MCGUIRE SB 946 PERSONAL
INCOME AND CORPORATION TAX
EXCLUSIONS, WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PAY, PAYMENTS. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1187 TRIBAL HOUSING
RECONSTRUCTION, RESTITUTION AND
RESILIENCY ACT MOTION IS DUE
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO
SENATOR MENGIBAR, WE'LL START AT
ON WITH SB 954 STUDENT HEALTH
CONTRACEPTIVE. THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED PER AUTHOR TO
MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 959 TRANS
INCLUSIVE HEALTH CARE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO REVISE TIMING
FOR WEBSITE UPDATES, AMEND TO
ALLOW FOR DONATIONS. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
1143, THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 987 PRETRIAL
RELEASE PRETRIAL ASSESSMENT
AGENCIES DO PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO ADD
LEGISLATIVE INTENT, AMEND TO
LIMIT THE USE OF COUNTY PRETRIAL
STAFF TO THREE SPECIFIED
COUNTIES. ROLL CALL, PLEASE.
CABALLERO A CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. JONES AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER I. BECKER
AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I.
CIERTO. CIERTO I WAHAB. WAHHAB I
. 7 TO 0 7 TO 0. THAT BILL IS
OUT SB 1033. CONGREGATE LIVING
HEALTH FACILITIES DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE RATE
ADJUSTMENTS AND REQUIRE A COST
ESTIMATE FOR PRIVATE DUTY
NURSING SERVICES. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1057 JUVENILE JUSTICE
COORDINATING COUNCIL MOTION IS
TO PASS, AS AMENDED, AMENDED TO
NARROW THE SCOPE WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 1069
STATE PRISONS OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO PERMIT THE OIG TO
MONITOR COMPLAINTS AND AMEND TO
DELETE OIG JOINT DECISION MAKING
AUTHORITY. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. 1079
THE YOUTH HOUSING BOND ACT OF
2024 MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
SPECIFY THE BOND AMOUNT AND
PROGRAM ALLOCATIONS. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143, THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. MOVING ON
TO 1112 MEDICARE MEDI-CAL. ALL
FAMILIES WITH SUBSIDIZED CHILD
CARE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1143 TERMINATION OF ELECTRIC
AND GAS SERVICES. THAT MOTION IS
42. Ó 1142. SHEESH OKAY, START
OVER. SB 1142 TERMINATES THÀNH
OF ELECTRIC AND GAS SERVICES.
MOTION IS Dð PASS NGUYEN TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1193 AIR THREE
AIRPORTS LEADED, AVIATION
GASOLINE. A MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
STRIKE AIRPORT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND IMPACTS TO
STATE AGENCIES. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CABALLERO A CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY A
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER I
BRADFORD. CIERTO. NO CIERTO. NO.
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 4242. THAT
BILL IS OUT SB 1281
SELF-DETERMINATION PROGRAM
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED PER
THE AUTHOR TO DELETE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO EMPLOYER BURDEN, COST
. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1323
COMPETENCE TO STAND TRIAL.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
CHANGES, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH THE
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. THEN SB
1497 POLLUTERS PLAY PAY CLIMATE
CHANGE, POLLUTERS PAY CLIMATE
COST RECOVERY ACT. THE MOTION IS
DO PASS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER I BECKER I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I. CIERTO.
CIERTO NO. WAHAB. WAHAB I 5 TO
2. 5 TO 2. THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO
SENATOR. MEN. FIRST UP IS SB 965
FIREARMS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR TO
CONSOLIDATE NEW DATA REPORTING
INTO AN EXISTING REPORT. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231, THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 972
METHANE EMISSIONS. LANDFILLS
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO REMOVE THE
MEETING REQUIREMENT, WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1078 LANGUAGE ACCESS MOTION
IS Dð PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE.
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1111 PUBLIC
OFFICERS CONTRACTS. FINANCIAL
INTEREST MOTION IS DUE. PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1221 PRIORITY
NEIGHBORHOOD DECARBONIZATION
ZONES PILOT PROJECTS MOTION IS
DUE PASS. I'M GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1242 CRIMES FIRES
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
ADD COAUTHORS. AND WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
BY UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1402 30 BY 30 GOAL. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH THE
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. MOVING ON
TO SENATOR NEWMAN. WE'LL START
WITH SB 897 STUDENT TRANSFERS,
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OF CHOICE.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO REMOVE THE
BASIC AID FORMULA INCREASE,
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THE BILL
IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. SB 907. ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION MOTION IS TO
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A 5 TO 2
VOTE, WITH THE REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1113 BCP PILOT
PROJECT EXTENSION MOTION IS DUE
PASS, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1119 HOSPITALS SEISMIC
COMPLIANCE. THIS MOTION IS TO
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1138 STUDENT
EXCUSED ABSENCES. MOTION IS DUE
PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1164. PROPERTY
TAXATION. NEW CONSTRUCTION
EXCLUSION. ADUS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REDUCE THE EXCLUSION
PERIOD. WE'RE GOING TO DO A ROLL
CALL ON THIS CABALLERO I,
CABALLERO I, JONES JONES I ASHBY
I ASHBY I BECKER BECKER I
BRADFORD I BRADFORD I SATO NO
SATO NO WAHAB NO. WAHAB NO. 5 TO
2. 5 TO 2. THAT BILL IS OUT. SB
1202 CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES REPORTS ASSAULTS
DO PASS IS THE MOTION. I'M GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1218 EMERGENCY WATER SUPPLIES
DO PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO STRIKE, INCENTIVIZE
AND SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1231. THIS BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1244 COLLEGE AND
CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS
PARTNERSHIPS. MOTION IS Dð PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THE BILL
IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. SB 1263 REPEAL OF
TEACHER PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT FOR
THE READING INSTRUCTION
COMPETENCE ASSESSMENT. WE'RE
GOING TO DO THIS ON A ROLL CALL,
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
JONES ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER
ALL RIGHT. BECKER I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CIERTO. WAHAB. NO.
WAHAB. NO 4 TO 1. 4 TO 1. THE
BILL IS OUT SB 1387 H VIP
ELIGIBILITY. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1416 SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO ADD A
COAUTHOR, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO SENATOR
NGUYEN. WE'LL START WITH SB
1214. UNITED STATES 250 50TH
ANNIVERSARY DO PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO ALIGN WITH
FEDERAL COMMISSION SUNSET DATE
AND TO ADD COAUTHORS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON THE UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. SB 1459 ANIMAL
SHELTERS DATA, THE ACTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO NARROW THE
SCOPE, WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
VOTE IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO
SENATOR NILO, SB 1176, THE ITS
WILDFIRES, TOXIC HEAVY METALS
MOTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO
MAKE CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION AND AUTHORIZE
CONTRACTING FOR RESEARCH ON
POTENTIAL MITIGATION MEASURES AS
SPECIFIED. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON
THE UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1413 YEAR ROUND STANDARD TIME.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO NARROW THE SCOPE,
MAKE CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION AND DELAY DATES,
THE. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1463 DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF SELF-DETERMINATION,
DO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231 AND THE BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
OKAY, WE'RE MOVING ON TO SENATOR
OCHOA BOGH. WE'LL START WITH SB
1108 MOBILE HOME PARKS. NOTICE
OF VIOLATIONS. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED, SO WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. AND THE BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1411 INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION MEMBERSHIP. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1442 POINT OF CARE
TESTS FOR FENTANYL DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO ADD A COAUTHOR AND
AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231 SO
THAT THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AND SB
1468 HEALING ARTS BOARDS FEDERAL
THREE DAY RULE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR,
TO CLARIFY INFORMATION
DISTRIBUTION METHOD AND TO AMEND
TO ADD A COAUTHOR SO WE'RE GOING
TO AGAIN DO A SUBSTITUTE ROLL
CALL FROM 1231 SB 1231. AND THE
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. OKAY. NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO SENATOR
PADILLA. WE'LL TAKE UP SB 892,
WHICH IS A PUBLIC CONTRACT.
STANDARDS. THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 893
CALIFORNIA I RESEARCH HUB MOTION
IS DUE PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED IN A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 990
STATE EMERGENCY PLAN LGBT PLUS
INDIVIDUALS. WE'RE GOING TO DO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AND THIS
IS A ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO A
CABALLERO AYE JONES. ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE.
CIERTO. WAHAB. WAHAB AYE. 5 TO
0. THE BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 0. SB
995. CSU HIGH QUALITY TEACHER
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1006 ELECTRIC TRANSMISSION GRID
ENHANCING TECHNOLOGIES. MOTION
IS DUE PASS. AGAIN, WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1032 HOUSING FINANCE LOAN
FORGIVENESS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR,
TO LIMIT LOAN FORGIVENESS TO
NONPROFIT SPONSORS WITH LOANS
NEARING MATURITY, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1070 STATES CIVIL
SERVICE TEMPORARY ASSIGNMENTS OR
LOANS. MOTION IS DUE PASS AND
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231 SO THAT
THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0 SB TEN,
SB 1105 PAID SICK LEAVE,
AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEES
EMERGENCIES. MOTION IS Dð PASS
BÀN TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1143. THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB
1178 CALIFORNIA WATER QUALITY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTION
ACT. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. AND SB 1208 WASTE DISCHARGE
PERMITS LANDFILLS. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THAT WHEN WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143, THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. ALL RIGHTY. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO SENATOR PORTANTINO.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH SB 971
COMMUNITY COLLEGE'S EXEMPTION OF
NONRESIDENT TUITION FEES. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO LIMIT THE EXEMPTION TO THREE
SPECIFIED COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
ESTABLISH A SUNSET. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH THE
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 997
PUPIL HEALTH KNOCKS ALONE AND
FENTANYL TEST STRIPS MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. SO THAT THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1100 DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND CAR OWNERSHIP DISCRIMINATION
THÀNH. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO DELETE PROVISIONS
REQUIRING ENFORCEMENT BY THE
CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT. THE
SUBSTITUTE. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A SUBSTITUTE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231 SO THAT THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1116 UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE TRADE DISPUTES,
ELIGIBILITY FOR BENEFIT CGRTS
MOTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 1128
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRATION. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
SB 1147 DRINKING WATER AND
MICROPLAS STICKS. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 0, WITH THE
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. A 5 TO 2,
I'M SORRY, 5 TO 2, SB 1192,
PERSONAL INCOME TAX, SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF ACT. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231, THE BILL
IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. SENATOR ROTH, FIRST
UP IS SB 895. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. BACCALAUREATE DEGREES
IN NURSING PROGRAM. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASSES, AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR, TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND TO ADD COAUTHORS.
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1231 SO THAT THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0, SB 902 FIREARM
PROHIBITIONS. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A ROLL CALL ON THIS. IT'S A
DUE PASS RECOMMENDATION.
CABALLERO A CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. NO JONES. NO. ASHBY A
ASHBY. AYE BECKER A BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE. SATO.
SATO. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 6
TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT. 6 TO 1.
SB 1042. CLINICAL NURSING
PLACEMENTS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. JONES. ASHBY. AYE
ASHBY AYE. BECKER I. BECKER.
AYE. BRADFORD I. BRADFORD. AYE.
CIERTO. WAHAB AYE. WAHAB. AYE. 5
TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 0
SB 1289 MEDI-CAL COUNTY CALL
CENTERS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 1385 MEDI-CAL
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER SERVICES
MOTION IS DUE PASS AGAIN, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231 SO THAT THE
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0 AND SB 1511
HEALTH OMNIBUS, THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AGAIN, THIS IS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH, IT'S A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION, WE'RE GOING
TO DO A WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO SENATOR
RUBIO, FIRST UP IS SB 1054,
CLIMATE CREDIT, NATURAL GAS
RATEPAYERS. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO DELETE,
ESTABLISHING A NEW GRANT PROGRAM
AND RETAIN THE NATURAL GAS
CLIMATE CREDIT FOR RESIDENTIAL
RATEPAYERS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS I'M SORRY.
OKAY. ROLL CALL. WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL ON THAT ONE, PLEASE. OKAY.
WE'LL DO A ROLL CALL ON THIS
ONE. AGAIN. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO DELETE.
ESTABLISHING A NEW GRANT PROGRAM
AND RETAIN THE NATURAL GAS
CLIMATE CREDIT FOR RESIDENTIAL
RATEPAYERS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. JONES
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO CIERTO.
NÓ. WAHAB. Ã. WAHAB. AYE 5 TO
1. THAT BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 1 SB
1230. TOBACCO ENFORCEMENT. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1391 TEACHER
TRAINING AND RETENTION
DASHBOARD. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
, AND WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 13 1231,
AND THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1419 FOOD DESERTS MOTION IS DUE
PASS. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO SB
916, NOW WE GET TO SENATOR SATO.
THE HIGHLIGHT OF THE HEARING.
WE'LL START WITH SB 916, TUITION
WAIVER OF EXTENDED EDUCATION
COURSES FOR VETERANS. THE MOTION
IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 920
CALIFORNIA PURPLE STAR SCHOOL
DESIGNATION PROGRAM. MOTION IS
TO PASS AGAIN. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 936
OPR STUDY ON ROAD SAFETY
PROJECTS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO NARROW THE SCOPE
OF THE REPORT, AND WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AND
SB 978. STATE BUDGET FORMAT. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO INSTEAD REQUIRE DOV TO
PROVIDE ELECTRONIC ACCESS TO THE
BUDGET. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
CONGRATULATIONS. THERE YOU GO,
MOVING ON TO SENATOR SKINNER.
WE'LL START WITH SB 899, FIRE
ARM PROTECTIVE ORDERS. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES, WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THAT BILL IS APPROVED
ON UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
906. STUDENT ATHLETES. ATHLETES
COMPENSATION. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT
BILL IS APPROVED ON UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB NINE 4041
SCOPING PLAN NATURAL. NATURAL. I
MEAN INDUSTRIAL SOURCES OF
EMISSIONS. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS A METHOD AS AMENDED PER
THE AUTHOR. TO NARROW THE SCOPE
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
FROM SB 1143 SO THAT THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
SB 950 REENTRY PROGRAMS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO DELETE
SPECIFIED ACTIVITIES. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM 1231. SO THAT THE BILL
IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0, SB 976 SOCIAL MEDIA.
YOUTH ADDICTION. THE MOTION IS
Dð PASS. WE'RE IN A SUBSTITUTE.
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THE
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH THE REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB TEN 2022
ENFORCEMENT OF CIVIL RIGHTS.
THIS MOTION IS TO PASS, AND
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143 SO THAT
THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2. SB 1073 STATE
PROCUREMENT LOW CARBON CEMENT OR
CONCRETE PRODUCTS. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM 1231. THAT BILL
IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0, AND SB 1144. THE
ONLINE MARKETPLACE. THE ACTION
IS DO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO ADD A
COAUTHOR, AND THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143, THAT THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
MOVING ON TO SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS, WE'LL START WITH SB
1067, HEALING ARTS EXPEDITED
LICENSURE PROCESS. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO NARROW THE SCOPE AND
SPECIFY PROCESSES. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE, TAKE A SUBSTITUTE.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THE BILL
IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. SB 1089 FOOD AND
PRESCRIPTION ACCESS, GROCERY AND
PHARMACY CLOSURES. WE'RE GOING
TO THE ACTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON
A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH THE
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 1282
DIVERSION. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
, AS AMENDED, TO SPECIFY
REQUIREMENTS FOR DIVERSION.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THE BILL
IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AND
SB 1340 DISCRIMINATION. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
1143. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AND SB 1446 GROCERY
AND RETAIL DRUG ESTABLISHMENT
EMPLOYEES SELF-SERVICE CHECKOUT
Dð PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES WHEN A SUBSTITUTE, THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143, THE BILL
IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
MOVING ON TO SENATOR STERN,
WE'LL START WITH SB 1277.
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
COLLABORATIVE FOR HOLOCAUST AND
GENOCIDE EDUCATION IN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CONTINGENT UPON AN APPROPRIATION
, WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THE BILL
IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. SB 1400 COMPETENCE TO
STAND TRIAL. MOTION IS DUE PASS.
I MEAN, YES, DO PASS. ROLL CALL
PLEASE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE JONES. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
WAHAB. WAHAB AYE. 5 TO 0. BILL
IS OUT. 5 TO 0. SB 1504
CYBERBULLYING PROTECTION ACT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
. TO NARROW THE SCOPE, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. ASHBY
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO
WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB AYE. FIVE ZERO
5 TO 0. THIS BILL IS OUT. SB
1508 ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEMS
MODELING. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CERTAIN ASPECTS ASPECTS ASPECTS
PERMISSIVE. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143, THE
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. SB 1509 EXCESSIVE SPEEDING.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE OFFERED AUTHOR, TO MOVE
THE BILLS. EXCESSIVE SPEEDING
VIOLATION TO THE RECKLESS
DRIVING STATUTE. THIS IS A ROLL
CALL VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
JONES. JONES. NO. ASHBY Ã.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. SATO
SATO. AYE. WAHAB. THAT'S GOING
TO BE 5 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT.
5 TO 1. OKAY. WE'RE MOVING ON TO
SENATOR UMBERG. SB 909,
PHYSICIAN LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM. THE ACTION IS Dð. PASS
AS AMENDED, TO ADD A COAUTHOR.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. AND THIS
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 910 TREATMENT
COURT PROGRAM STANDARDS MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED AT A
COAUTHOR. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE, THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231, THE BILL
IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. SB 914 MILITARY
VETERANS EMPLOYMENT Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
AN APPROPRIATION. AGAIN, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 919 THIRD PARTY
FRANCHISE SELLERS MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO PROVIDE EXEMPTION AND
TO CLARIFY REQUIREMENTS. AND
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. AGAIN.
THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AND SB
939 EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
NEURODIVERGENT STUDENTS MOTION
IS DUE PASS WITH THE WITH THE
SUBSTITUTION OF THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB 1231. THE BILL IS
APPROVED WITH ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. NOW WE HIT
SENATOR WAHAB NØ. WE'LL START
WITH SB 926 DISTRIBUTION OF
INTIMATE IMAGES. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR, TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR SB
1231. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 980
MEDI-CAL DENTAL BENEFITS. THE
MOTION. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
NARROW THE DENTAL BENEFIT AND
AMEND TO REQUIRE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 982
CRIMES. ORGANIZED THEFT. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO ADD COAUTHORS. AND AGAIN,
WE'RE USING THIS SUBSTITUTE ROLL
CALL FROM 1231. THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 983 GAS STATIONS AND
ALTERNATIVE FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AGAIN USING
THE SUBSTITUTE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 1 7 TO 0
7 TO 0. I'M SORRY, SB 984 PUBLIC
AGENCIES PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS. MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED TO REMOVE DGS AND
DTSC. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1143. THE
BILL IS APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
. SB 1318 STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS INTERVENTION PROTOCOLS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1143, THE BILL IS APPROVED ON
A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. SB 1319
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO ADD COAUTHORS. AND AGAIN,
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231 SO THAT
THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB
1321 EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL
PROJECTS AND PROPOSALS. MOTION
IS DUE PASS, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2 AND SB 1322. THE
CHAFEE EDUCATIONAL AND TRAINING
VOUCHERS PROGRAM MOTION IS DUE
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
EXPANSION TO THE AGES OF 15 TO
18 YEARS OLD, THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO
SENATOR WIENER, SB, WE'LL START
WITH THIS FIRST BILL, SB 905
CRIMES THEFT FROM A VEHICLE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO ADD A COAUTHOR. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231, THAT BILL IS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. SB 951
COASTAL DEVELOPMENT MOTION IS Dð
PASS. AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1231. THE BILL IS PASSED IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE TO
7 TO 0. SB 957 DATA COLLECTION,
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND GENDER
IDENTITY. THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
AND AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 960 TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING COMPLETE STREETS AND
TRANSIT PRIORITY PROJECTS.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO NARROW THE
MANDATE FOR TRANSIT PRIORITY
FACILITIES ON SHOP PROJECTS AND
MAKE A CLARIFYING CHANGE. AMEND
TO NARROW THE MANDATE FOR BIKE
PEDESTRIAN IMPROVEMENTS ON SHOP
PROJECTS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 966 PHARMACY
BENEFIT MANAGERS. THE MOTION IS
Dð PASS AND NGUYEN TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. THE
BILL IS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE, 7 TO 0. SB 969 ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES ENTERTAINMENT ZONE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 988 FREELANCE WORKER
PROTECTION ACT MOTION IS DUE
PASS, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
1143. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. SB 1031 SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA LOCAL REVENUE MEASURE.
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS,
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO REQUIRE MTC TO DEVELOP AN
EXPENDITURE EXPENDITURE PLAN
WITH COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY APPROVAL, PROHIBIT
PLACEMENT OF A REGIONAL MEASURE
ON THE BALLOT IN NORTHERN
COUNTIES UNTIL 2028, AND MAKE
OTHER SPECIAL SPECIFIED CHANGES.
THE. WE WILL SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1143. THAT BILL IS
APPROVED ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
SB 1047 MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
DELETE SPECIFIED PROVISIONS
RELATING RELATING TO THE
FRONTIER MODEL DIVISION. THIS IS
A ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. JONES ASHBY AYE.
ASHBY AYE. BECKER BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. SATO
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 5 TO 0. 5 TO
0. THAT BILL IS OUT. AND LAST
BUT NOT LEAST, SENATOR WILK.
SECOND ON ON WINNERS
.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING BACK TO
SENATOR WILK, FIRST UP IS SB
TEN. OH FOUR. INCOME TAX
EXCLUSIONS, WILDFIRE YEAR. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AND WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB 1231. THE BILL IS
APPROVED WITH UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. SB 1233 èC
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR SPAY
AND NEUTER TECHNIQUES. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. AND I AND
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB 1231. BILL IS
APPROVED ON ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0, AND SB 1359 ILLEGAL
DUMPING. THE MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO REMOVE PENALTY
INCREASED. AS WE'RE IN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB 1231. THE BILL IS APPROVED ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. WE
HAVE A COUPLE THINGS TO GO BACK
TO, OKAY? WE HAVE OUR OPEN. OH
THAT'S RIGHT. AND THEN I THINK
THEY'RE ASKING FOR A
RECONSIDERATION. I WANT TO 1451
15 SO ON THAT MOTION. MADAM
CHAIR, YES. ARE WE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO ASK FOR SOME
RECONSIDERATION ON TWO BILLS,
YES. I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
REQUEST AND I AM PREPARED TO
ENTERTAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
OKAY. A RECONSIDERATION ON SB
1450 BY ALAN. ALAN ALAN. SORRY
OKAY. YEAH. GIVE ME A SECOND TO
GET. AND THE SECOND ONE, SB 1081
ARCHULETA. RIGHT OKAY. I DON'T
KNOW IF WE CAN DO THAT ONE,
BECAUSE. IF HE CHANGES HIS VOTE,
IT'LL CHANGE THE OUTCOME FOR
SOMEBODY. WHAT? OH, I SEE IF
THERE WAS THAT AMENDMENT. YEAH
AMENDMENT. THE AMENDMENT
EXEMPTED AB 60 HOLDERS BECAUSE
THEY. WE ALSO HAVE ONE BILL
THAT'S ON CALL. SO I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THAT UP AS WELL.
WE'RE BACK, ON THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE A RECONSIDERATION ON ON SB
1450, WHICH IS AN ALLEN BILL. IS
THAT CORRECT? THAT'S CORRECT.
OKAY. AND SO, THERE IS A MOTION
MADE FOR RECONSIDERATION. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO THAT
MOTION SEEING NO OBJECTION, IT
WILL BE GRANTED. AND WE WILL
RECALL, SB 1450, MOTION IS Dð
PASS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. NARBONNE. ASHBY AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE. SATO.
WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 0. 5 TO
0. THAT BILL IS OUT, SO WE NEED
TO GO BACK TO A BILL THAT WE
LEFT ON CALL, WHICH IS, ON, ON,
SENATOR GLASER. GLASER IT IS SB
1327. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
DEFINE TERMS AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES, MODIFY FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS, AND ADD COAUTHORS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BECKER
BRADFORD. I HAVE GREAT CONCERNS
REGARDING THIS MEASURE, BUT I'M
GOING TO GIVE IT CONSIDERATION
TODAY AND HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR
MAKES CONTINUED COMMITMENTS TO
IMPROVE IT. SO I WILL VOTE AYE
FOR NOW. BRADFORD. AYE THAT BILL
IS OUT 4 TO 2. THE BILL IS OUT 4
TO 2. THAT COVERS ALL OF OUR
BUSINESS. SO THAT, THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR THE
DAY. I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
HERE FOR BEING HERE PROMPTLY AND
BEING ENGAGED AND READY TO ROLL.
I WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE POSTING THE
HEARING RESULTS ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE, AND THERE WILL BE AN
ADDENDUM ANALYSIS THAT WILL BE
HOSTED SHORTLY FOR ALL ITEMS
THAT WERE AMENDED TODAY. SO THIS
MEETING OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU. EVERYBODY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH